20:18 was tough because i'd pretty much
decided that I was done I didn't want to
keep I didn't want to keep playing
anymore because I wasn't enjoying
anything about tennis anymore wasn't
enjoying the training wasn't enjoying
the matches winning was not fun either I
mean a lot of things happen the last
couple of years but you certainly
realized some things kind of when you
get through the other side of like your
issues I remember better know what's you
know what's important you know the
health is your number number-one
priority and you know your family and
stuff when I was going through this you
know I was worried about worrying about
tennis and oh if I can't play tennis
anymore what am I gonna do but the last
three months after I had the the second
operation on my hip the resurfacing I
kind of realized all of that because my
pain was gone and then I was just able
to do day-to-day things with my family
that I hadn't been able to do for a you
know a long time and I was I was happy
and I was enjoying joying life again
which you know certainly wasn't for the
sort of 18 months previous what does the
future hold for you what goals have you
set for the new season are they are they
high goals or they're quite modest goals
because you're with Rafa and Novak last
week at the Davis Cup you know I are you
closer to them now in terms of your game
well like I mean I could set goals and
say you know I want to win Wimbledon
want to do all those things but actually
again that's one of the things I've sort
of learned you know over this last
period is that you know winning tennis
matches is nice but it's not you know
it's not the most important thing I want
to try to be healthy next year but also
the reason why I play tennis is not just
to win Wimbledon or anything that play
tennis I love it and that's why I
started playing in the first place
something that maybe you forget when
you're competing and become a
professional you know that you forget
that this is why you got into the sport
you end up putting lots of pressure on
results and rankings and things like
that but ultimately so long as I'm I'm
pain free and playing tennis you know I
do it because because I love it we're in
the run-up to an election run-up to
brexit you know if the tennis thing
doesn't work out could you see yourself
ever going into politics to sort the
whole mess out well in the current
climate that's for sure you've got to
stay well clear of that
I always I do always take an interest in
politics but a bit of a shambles just
now